do you think about your own mortality
death sure
are you afraid Wow death I released the
theory during something that can kill
older people sure I was there of course
let a bit of a parallel that of course
of course I don't want it to die with me
what do you hope your legacy is oh I
hope my legacy is accurate I'd like to
ride on my accomplishments rather than
how my community decided to ding me
while I was alive that would be great
what about if it was significantly
exaggerated I don't want it you wanted
to be accurate well I've got some pretty
terrific stuff and then whether it works
out or doesn't that I would like it to
reflect what I actually was I'll settle
for a cure what would you say what is
the greatest element of Eric Weinstein
accomplishment in life terms of being
accurate like what what are you most
proud of trying
the idea that we were stalled out in it
in the hardest field at the most
difficult juncture and then I didn't
listen to that voice ever it said stop
you're hurting yourself you're hurting
your family hurting everybody you're
embarrassing yourself you're screwing up
you can't do this you're a failure
you're a fraud turn back save yourself
like that voice
I didn't ultimately listen to it and it
was going for 35 37 years very hard and
I hope you never listen to that voice
that's why you're an inspiration thank
you appreciate
you